In this video, we're going to
do an example in which we
derive the probability density
function of the sum of two
random variables.
The problem tells us
the following.
We're given that X and Y are
independent random variables.
X is a discrete random
variable with PMF Px.
Y is continuous with PDF Fy.
And we'd like to compute the PDF
of Z which is equal to X
plus Y. We're going to use the
standard approach here--
compute the CDF of Z
and then take the
derivative to get the PDF.
So in this case, the CDF, which
is Fz, by definition is
the random variable Z being
less than little z.
But Z is just X plus Y. So now,
we'd actually like to,
instead of having to deal with
two random variables, X and Y,
we'd like to deal with
one at a time.
And the total probability
theorem allows us to do this
by conditioning on one of the
two random variables.
Conditioning on Y here is a
bit tricky, because Y is
continuous, and you have to be
careful with your definitions.
So conditioning on X seems
like the way to go.
So let's do that.
This is just the probability
that X equals little x, which
is exactly equal to the PMF
of X evaluated at x.
Now we're given we're fixing
X equal to little x.
So we can actually replace every
instance of the random
variable with little x.
And now I'm going to just
rearrange this so that it
looks a little nicer.
So I'm going to have Y on the
left and say Y is less than z
minus x, where z minus
x is just a constant.
Now, remember that X and
Y are independent.
So telling us something about X
shouldn't change our beliefs
about Y. So in this case,
we can actually drop the
conditioning.
And this is exactly the CDF of
Y evaluated at z minus x.
So now we've simplified
as far as we could.
So let's take the derivative and
see where that takes us.
So the PDF of Z is, by
definition, the derivative of
the CDF, which we just
computed here.
This is sum over x
Fy z minus x Px.
What next?
Interchange the derivative
and the summation.
And a note of caution here.
So if x took on a finite number
of values, you'd have a
finite number of terms here.
And this would be completely
valid.
You can just do this.
But if x took on, for
example, a countably
infinite number of values--
a geometric random variable,
for example--
this would actually require
some formal justification.
But I'm not going to
get into that.
So here, the derivative with
respect to z-- this is
actually z--
is you use chain rule here.
Px doesn't matter, because
it's not a function of z.
So we have Fy evaluated at z
minus x according to the chain
rule, and then the derivative of
the inner quantity, z minus
x, which is just 1.
So we don't need to put
anything there.
And we get Px of x.
So there we go.
We've derived the PDF of z.
Notice that this looks quite
similar to the convolution
formula when you assume that
both X and Y are either
continuous or discrete.
And so that tells us that
this looks right.
So in summary, we've basically
computed the PDF of X plus Y
where X is discrete and
Y is continuous.
And we've used the standard
two-step approach--
compute the CDF and then take
the derivative to get the PDF.